To generate a web application, you can use the web
app factory. Simply putting in some details of what you
want to build here for this demo we will implement
Implements a graphing calculator. Save your idea. Make
sure that you have some models selected. We're going to
be using Gemini three flash preview. For this demo
you do have to have an image model selected even
if you aren't using it. It doesn't have to be
actually an image model. You just have to select something
And then we go to pipeline and build web app
This is the only step in this pipeline, but this
step is quite involved. It starts by generating a Project
plan of tasks and then executes them. Appropriately
keeping in mind all of their dependencies and as you
will see in a moment. Here
we see the project plan with 5 different tasks. It's
Of course these nodes are not displaying correctly, but we
can view the tasks themselves here. So
here it creates the foundational documents for the project, implements
HTML structure. Visual style, now it's implementing. Once
it is complete, the web app UI will update. The
implementation step is done and we can see the read
me in the project root. At this point, we can
download the zip if you want. Also notable is that
this application has Git support integrated into it. If the
implementation is done, we can also launch the app. And
here we see we are plotting sin of x. What
happens if we say sin of x plus 10 of
x? Here we go. That looks about right. Or what
about divide instead of times? What about Times
Oh, power, that looks interesting. Anyway, it seems to work
but you know what? It's too bright. Let's
ask for some changes. Update. We can update our web
app using the updateator. You know we can say, Implement
a dark theme. And a theme. Save
our notes and run the update. This will update our
project with our requested updates. This can also be useful
if you see bugs or 100. Feature or really any
change. The update is done. Let's go look at our
caffeine calculator, refresh it, and oh. We've got a theme
button, and it works. So that's how to use the
web app factory to generate your own applications. We can
also collect usage. And we can see that this entire
project demo cost.